I like doing that but gentlemen I'll be
ready
thank you I did John I've been told it's
quarter past by somebody I believe on my
right hand side right thank you very
much good evening and welcome to
Stratford District Council's planning
east committee
my name's Andy Crump and I will be
chairing tonight's meeting and the
purpose of the meeting is to examine the
planning merits of the applications
being present today again before we
start the meeting can I ask members of
the public to insure their mobile phones
are either switched off or put on silent
and there's nothing worse than the
speaker be not interrupted by the theme
- dancing queen as they if we mentioned
party conferences today could also
please respectfully remind members of
the public not to show tape when people
are speaking however tempting it may be
as only registered speakers are allowed
to speak I'd like to introduce my
colleagues at top table starting with
unbinds from committee services Jaime
Parsons legal advisor can Tate I'm the
team leader planners East in my role as
an impartial advisor to the committee I
can clarify any planning issues that
arise doing so unbound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the art EPI
planning committee members are not bound
by the case officers recommendation or
by oral advice James Hodgkins planner
thank you and just a small note small
word to say this is James's last meeting
with us came to the dark side I think
he's going to the private sector I
believe right James thank you right
item 1 on the agenda policies for
absence
chairman we have apologies from
councillor Kendall for whom councillor
courage is substituting and apologies
from councillors Perry in st. Thank You
council Claridge nice card
right a little number to dispose of
interests House members thank you -
number three minutes have everyone read
the minutes and happy that I can sew on
them later and we now move on to item 4
which is application number 18 / 0 187
for you to land adjacent to the bungalow
hocum Lane in Upton on the hill Curran
will be presenting this on thank you
Thank You chair application details on
page 15 of your committee papers the
application seeks outline permission
with all matters reserved for the
construction of 8 dwellings to be
located at the land adjacent to the
bungalow howcome Lane Knapton is located
on the block plan and black dot the
application is outlined in red is
situated to the north western edge of
the villages village directly to the
east of howcome Lane and north of the
residential properties along Cox's Lane
there is an appeal currently pending
following delegated refusal for seven
dwellings on the site a public
right-of-way dissect the site the report
is amended in relation to highways
comments
which are now set out in your updated
update sheet the plan shows the
indicative layout of the development
whilst providing a useful visual aid
it must be highlighted that the layout
is reserved for future consideration as
such the plan that you see before you is
for illustrative purposes only
this shows the indicative sight sections
and the amended access great unit as you
can see the site rises in the in an
easterly direction up from howcome Lane
and in a northerly direction up from
Cox's Lane
I now have a number of photos of the
site to show you you will note the
location plan in the bottom left-hand
corner shaves the rough position in
which the photographs were taken and the
direction in which they face first
photograph this is looking north east
towards the old bakery and villains
cottage second photograph this is
looking West back towards the bungalow
and the associate associated
agricultural style buildings photo 3
this and the following photo look south
towards the adjoining neighbors in Cox's
Lane photograph 5 this look southwest
towards the proposed access next
photograph this shows the adjoining
highway access will be taken to the left
as shown next photograph this looks
north across the remainder of the field
within the applicants ownership and
final images show that character of the
associated field when viewed from the
highway the application is recommended
refusal for the reasons outlined within
the committee report thank you kind of
our first speaker space which is
canceled easy and Khosla Heath from
Knapton Parish Council
Oh John you've got three minutes good
evening everyone thank you so who's
operating the the projector right so if
I raise my hand will you just change the
light thank you
so this is Knapton parish councils
response to the outlined planning
application so first we're going to talk
about our highways issues that we have
which are different to those that have
been highlighted by the Highways
Authority and based on our local
knowledge so this is an attempt to try
and show where the access point is on
howcome lane it is in fact at the
narrowest point and would make access
quite difficulty it's very restrictive
also on the opposite side of the the
road you will see that there is a green
Bank more or less opposite the the arrow
and that is where the splay vision
angles will have to be cut into that
Bank making some quite significant
changes to the traditional character of
that Lane this next picture without the
arrow is to show the nature of how come
Lane in its entirety
there is no footpath and we have a
significant number of villages who have
to walk down that road in the road there
is no intention to build a path at the
moment and we believe that with the
additional traffic this will make the
journey of quite a lot of people going
to the village shop in the school more
hazardous this is just a shot showing an
ordinary typically a typical evening in
the village where you see a number of
cars going up that side we are concerned
that although there are parking spaces
for visitors within the proposed
development we don't believe there are
enough and we believe that will lead to
a significant increase of parking on
howcome Lane which will exacerbate the
already difficult traffic flow issues
that we have there so we're now going to
move on to some landscape issues and
these were largely been covered in the
planners batons but so as you can see
the Coxes Lane in the in the background
the new development is significantly
higher because of the nature of the
elevated site and we are concerned that
this will be an imposition on current
properties and is contrary to policy CS
9 b8 the open nature of the site whilst
it's not a beautiful piece of land it is
open and is characteristic of the nature
of the village to keeping pockets of
green space and they out the developing
neighbourhood plan that we are in final
draft wishes to protect the spaces for
the future to keep the open character of
the village the site is wholly outside
the recently established and seemed to
be ratified built-up area boundary so we
also stopped concerned that 15 seconds
okay
sorry if you go to the last page we've
recently done the housing needs survey
and this shows the output from that
thank you
any questions John I'll see you cut off
in your prime there the BU IB place yeah
sure the the obviously a lot of the
local service villages under the core
strategy have now been given some
suggested built-up area boundaries the
Neighborhood Development Group within
Knapton has debated these long and hard
as to whether we wanted to change it and
we had several attempts but in the end
we settled with the boundary that was
offered to us by Stratford planners so
that is the original layout including
things like the allotments and the top
of what we know as the locally is the AC
Lloyd Development which is further in
the village and we've already had two
properties
granted on appeal at the end of
Jackson's Lane which are currently
outside the built-up area boundary we
are concerned that if these get granted
it makes a complete mockery of the built
up area boundary process and
kind of nullifies part of the
fundamentals of the core strategy it's
all I can offer for now thank you so can
we just have a look at the housing
survey again thank you thank you yes we
were consulted as I said we the Parish
Council and the Neighborhood Development
Group had several soul-searching debates
as to whether it was appropriate and I
don't know whether this is appropriate
for me to mention on the sheet that I
couldn't get to we have the Brickyard
site which is brownfield site on the
edge of the village which is a reserved
site which has the potential for up to
80 houses so we think we've met our
limit sorry thank you opposite side
looks like it's ready for development as
I say we wanted to maintain the small
pockets of green space within the
village to keep the rural nature if
we've we felt that if it was filled in
its entirety it just becomes like an
urban sprawl thank you any more
questions no thank you thank you guys
Phase II have our next speaker please
which is mr. Tim barber
hello miss BBQ put your right colleges
and you've got three minutes okay fine
okay as I say I'm Tim barber and this
evening
I speak for myself my wife and for mr.
and mrs. Watts and number two got his
Lane Knapton immediate neighbors our
objections to the original application
for this 17025 nine one well based on
several concerns including but not
limited to the sustainable development
and core strategy issues overlooking an
overbearing which has popped up on the
screen there and highway safety all our
original objections plus additional
comments dated twenty second twenty
eight and thirty first of all she may
invalid for us in relation to this
current application 1800 one 874 the
original application initially for nine
properties and revised to seven
properties on this site was refused in
March 2018 failing to satisfy several
policies within the struck four core
strategy in part due to the I've ated
nature of the set that the site which
would be visible from some distance
causing harm to the rural character of
this side of the village and it would
also have as shown in the slide you've
seen her direct and significant visual
impacts on houses that surround the site
on three sides and indeed due to the
elevated nature of the site and based on
plans that we've seen submitted we
believe there are some existing houses
where as being one of them where the new
development ground floor level may look
down on existing upstairs levels this
current planning application has been
brought to committee on the
recommendation of councillor Williams
following his comments dated 12th and
20th of August and a councillor Williams
did not support the original application
stating and I cannot support the
application since the proposal is
outside the built area of the village
which is still is and the quantity
required would significantly increase
the number of houses allowed in the core
strategy this development is not wanted
a local community who are keen to
support their doctor core strategy now
you have in front of you whose detailed
comments relating to this current
application in the reason he give for
supporting it that the mix of housing
meets the core strategy and that the
housing is appropriate for the community
of Knapton and are given that the
outline plan is largely unchanged other
than it increases the number of
dwellings to AIDS that the core strategy
appears unchanged from March 2018 that
the community of Knapton appears
unchanged in its opinions on the
development itself and that the
application fails to satisfied those
core strategy policies for which the
original application was refused we do
not feel this application merits
approval 30 seconds for so many eyes
upon this application those of directly
affected parties villages generally in
landowners we feel that the
consideration of planning applications
must be consistent particularly in
relation to core strategy requirements
on the screen based on where the sorry
to finish your question just based on
where the property would be situated on
the last plans they would look down into
our upstairs from their downstairs thank
you
wherever you look at from a scenery and
therefore become very much part of the
village why would this not be the same I
don't see any point in making it worse
you're right there are lots of different
elevated areas within Knapton but the
parish council stated it's important
that we keep some green areas within the
village to break it up otherwise it just
looks like a sprawl the problem with
this site is that you can see it from a
very long distance literally miles
changes the whole rural aspect of the
village on that side of the village next
speakers are still filled and mr. Warner
will you both be speak your mr. upfield
okay everybody you've got six mates and
you've got one shot if you want with for
30 seconds together if you need overtime
thank you thank you
as this application is in outline form
only with all matters reserved the main
planning consideration appears to be
whether or not the site lies within the
village confines when determining an
application a well behaved planning
committee should follow a clear and
consistent advice of their paid
professionals the planning offices
unfortunately in this case the planning
officers do not appear to be clear or
consistent on this point as recommended
in the national planning policy
framework the applicant paid for
pre-application advice prior to
submission of a formal application the
planning officers report said and I
quote I am of the opinion
that the site is within the physical
conflict on the strength of this advice
the applicant submitted the first
application and after negotiation with
the Department the planning officer sent
me an email stating that and I quote
again I have now discussed the amended
scheme with my line manager and believe
in principle the site is suitable for
the construction of seven dwellings
shortly after that further email was
received saying that the officer now had
a new line manager and I quote again I
have got to make a u-turn on the
principle of development shortly after
that the original application was
refused at officer level one assumes
that this change of heart came about
because of the draft and I must
emphasize that word draft the draft
built-up areas boundary plan where the
site was shown outside the draft back
line it must be noted that in June this
year an appeal was granted in Jackson
Lane and mountain where the government
planning inspector stated I give the
draft built-up areas boundary relatively
little weight in the context of the
appeal I understand that the similar
conclusions have been made by inspectors
in other appeals recently so returning
to the question is the site within the
physical confines if we can look at the
photograph that's on the board please on
this the site is sorry not the first one
please Japs no no no that my first
cheers thank you so on this photograph
the site he's hatched red and the
surrounding residential land over the
village is hatched pink this area in
orange was previously part of the
residential garden of the bungalow
having considered this my opinion
is that there is no obvious hard edge to
the village in this location
there is clearly development to both
sides east and west of how come Lane as
well as to the north and south in fact
the area hatched in the cyan sort of
bluey color shows an extent consent for
a new detached dwelling on the opposite
side of how come Lane I understand this
development was recommended for refusal
by the planning officers but yet was
approved by this very committee in 2016
so in conclusion there does not appear
to be consistent advice from planning
officers and inspectors and the issue is
certainly not clear yeah so I would
simply ask that committee members make
up their own minds as to whether or not
the site is within the village confines
please also remember current government
policy in that there is a presumption in
favor of sustainable development that's
pretty much all I was bad to say at the
beginning having listened to the parish
council I don't think anything changes
they've talked about the access road but
yet we have no objection from the
highways people I think James as in his
report points out that we the indicative
scheme meets with all the design
guidance in terms of separation
distances and there wouldn't be
overlooking that he's unacceptable and I
think in conclusion that sort of like to
say thank you
is Mark Warner sorry I knew of the
farmer yes
and we're and this this is an
agricultural field you graze or very
poor grazing around anyway so it's let
the bone below
these horses graze it and it's just that
boundary that we can see there that goes
around it or do you let the whole all
the way up to the top and it's the
grazing better at the top of the hill
I've got one question you met mr.
Rothfeld you mentioned 2016 when the
yeah that was part the core strategy
been adopted wasn't it
it would have been prior to the core
strategy yeah so I think what it proves
is that your committee are also
uncertain about where the village or
village is no I think there was I think
because prior to that core strategy been
adopted and issues with five years heads
in non suppliers also and there's more
presumption in five versus sustainable
development yeah but that wasn't the
advice that your officer gave okay thank
you any any other questions thank you
gentlemen thank you very much it's no
ward member today so we'll move on to
points of clarification and he points of
clarification for Karen or James no I've
got a couple it's probably one for James
and current and one for Jamie there was
the issue raised by mr. field regarding
the pre-application the physical
confines of Bui B is there any more
updates on that or give us a bit more
clarification on that place yes the
pre-application was written by an
ex-colleague
at the time writing I think the be a
rabies hadn't been through cabinet that
predated Cabinet decision that they
would apply them the view from the the
subsequent case officer was that in fact
applying the assessment flying the B UAB
Maps which I accept our are not adopted
at this point in time if it met the
criteria for for sitting outside the be
UAB and that's even if you apply the the
original
the local plan local plan position so we
are strongly of the view that this is
outside the big UAB one for you Charlie
please obviously more clarification
about the weight of the BMI be
especially in the context of the recent
appeals and is that appeal which is
about giving white is that a blanket
approach for the whole area or is it
just based on individual cases please
thank you chairman I should appreciate
with a lot of Donovan plans and
documents that are to be relied on when
considering any application before you
they gather weight that the nearer they
get being adopted you should be well
aware that although you have a local
plan here at the time when it was coming
up to adoption you could afford it more
weight to those aspects that weren't in
dispute I would agree with the inspector
rightly say that all as it's not been
adopted it should not be given full
weight it is a matter I would suggest
for the committee to look more of the
terms of the policy where it makes
reference and if I can just quote where
it talks about either within the built
up edge or area boundary of a local
service village aware defined or
otherwise within the physical confines
and that's really what's before you
tonight is whether you believe it's
within the physical confines of the
village because the be UAB hasn't been
fully adopted but I would say that it
can have limited weight put to it but
not full weight by any means saying
because of the development of in all
these sorry the planning application in
16 which is the one on the other side of
the road does that not almost square off
the field as being part of
the built-up area boundary but it makes
more of an infill than it would
otherwise be in relation to that it's it
doesn't affect in the sense the built-up
area boundary that's been accepted and
being proposed to be adopted because it
doesn't hold to that it was as the chair
stated ready was an application that was
down with before the local plan was
adopted its each application is again as
you appreciate is determinants own
merits and the application before you is
really turns on that point whether or
not this development is as you say
within the confines of the village with
the built-up area boundary plan as your
officers as the officer has said within
the report this falls without sight the
built a barrier boundary I appreciate
it's not a straight answer but I'm
afraid it's not Chairman through you
that's a planning judgment it's whether
or not the planners wish to add anything
further it's not for me to say yes or no
it's for you to consider that under the
planning balance
yeah I think the report very clearly
sets out the position the guidelines the
annex three guidelines which you can
fall back on do say that to be included
within the confines a undeveloped areas
which are churches community buildings
playing fields are excluded areas of
residential Kirtley jeunesse these areas
are clearly paddocks more appropriately
defined as non-urban the applicant list
stated this is agricultural land our
view is that this sits outside the be
UAB and I would refer you to the last
committee green ground top Street North
End where you have a similar
consideration and refused that
application as being outside to be UAB
map area just looking in the conclusions
can you just explain a little bit more
about the gradient and the refuse
vehicles and what that actually means
does that mean that emergency bits as
well wouldn't be able to get 30 yes
sorry Joe thank you yeah okay any
further points of clarification shall we
go on to the debate we would not just
art catch the barns
it's very important that they have had
advice and it sort of was going their
way and then it turned I think this is a
particular site that we you know an
inspector would look after and make a
judgment on because I think it could go
either way
but as we are at the moment at this at
the village boundary or appears to be
now and the numbers are greater than
they were before and I can't really with
the parish council objecting the local
subjecting I can't really support this
and have to go along with the opposite
but I do feel concerned for the
applicant who not been led astray but
you know what's going on the right
direction because most people don't go
for advice and then all of a sudden they
you know mode at the district council so
I'm happy to support the application and
propose the application for refusal the
brime happy to speak German there's no
real change from the refusal we gave
back earlier in the year
apart from a u-turn by the ward member
and an addition of an extra house and
from what we've heard I feel it falls
outside the physical confines of the
built-up area and I was second in
Cervantes the feeling I recognize what
Karen said about Knapton is one that I
don't have seen he's totally different
in that you had a playing field the
other side of it whereas this has got
houses on the other side of the road and
in my view it is very much infill to an
area of the village it's within the road
and it is very poor agricultural land
and I believe it should be granted I'm
torn with this one because I think we
have to give weight to the BU a B and
the amount of time the parish councils
put in to assisting with demarcating the
BU a B but I agree with councillor
fielding that given the other
development that's proposed around it it
could quite neatly fit into looking a
little bit like infill carriage yeah
well I support the officers on this one
I think as far as physical confines go
to me it's quite clearly outside the
physical confines of the village
obviously outside the proposed boundary
looking at the agent the applicant some
on map when that came up even if you
took that the garden you know if it is
gone and it looks like paddock enjoying
it yeah if you take the yellow hatch and
during it on to the bungalow or the farm
building what is it whatever it is
further to the north you've still got
that whole area to the right which is
clearly attached to a bunch of greens so
I think it's clearly outside the
physical confines we've heard more
evidence on design and distinctiveness
about the nature of the that the Lane
having to change because the of the y
display is cutting into the banks we've
got we've heard new evidence I think for
the Parish Council on this desire being
talked about in their in their plan to
retain these pockets of open spaces
which this is the housing mix as well I
mean I would have to go into housing mix
frankly but the housing mix is not what
the need survey suggests it's not what
the district council suggests so I see
no reason to go against the previous
decision of this yeah we've had a
proposed that on a second to refuse the
application coastal votes all those in
favor to refuse application
two-three-four chairman all those
against one chairman absolute one chen
committee resolves to refuse
supplication 18/2 zero one eight seven
four o UT thank you now move on to our
next item okay sir
okay can we can we just then thank you
can we move on to move on the next item
on the agenda which is application 1800
806 Effie well Lund to the south of
Tysoe road curtain before coining sorry
about that
yeah and we'll be presenting this on
Johnson Thank You mr. chairman the
application site is south of is pointin
in a rural location and is shown by the
black dot the application involves a
replacement agricultural building which
would be accessed off the main road from
an existing an existing field access
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
yeah that's tiny it's set in
agricultural fields with no immediate
neighbors the new agricultural building
proposed is approximately 10 by 11
meters would be located would be located
in the green rectangle approximately 74
meters from the road the footprint of
the existing building is shown by the
smaller grey rectangle
this slide shows plans and elevations of
the building fairly typical design with
green metal box profile cladding roller
shutter doors and a corrugated roof it
would be six meters to the ridge and
four point eight meters to the eaves
this slide shows the view of the
dilapidated
there are lots of dilapidated
agricultural building from the existing
field access this is the closer close
the photograph of the barn that will be
replaced and this this slide shows the
view from the site of the building back
towards the road with the access to the
extreme left of the picture you can see
the hedgerows and the trees which run
along the road further on the right hand
side
mr. chairman there are no updates so the
recommendation mr. chairman is to
approve the application for the reasons
detailed in the report thank you Thank
You Anton come over the first speakers
please which is catch the Gosling and
cancel through this from current and
parish council
I think we'll get some name plates made
up for you gentlemen I don't know I'm
sure you know another score going on are
you both speaking
I'll speak it might be some answering
questions okey-dokey thank you thank you
good evening counsellors and officers
we've approached this application from
the very start with a recognition that
as an agricultural building it is
supporting rural and local business
where we have expressed concerns they
have in part been dealt with for example
the original size of 170 square meters
has been reduced to 123 square meters as
a result of the conclusions of Kernan
the countryside consultants commissioned
by the planning officer we note that the
original plan was approximately 38.5
percent larger in area than the one
before you this tonight is referred to
in the report as slightly larger where
your main concern is with the location
please show pitch one can uncomment that
it would not be unreasonable for the
proposed building to be sited just
inside the gate where it'd be less
visible screened by the mature hedging
and there is no agricultural
justification for the proposed
replacement building to be sited at the
far edge to give you some idea of what a
120 square meter with a 6 meter height
orig looks like you were past one every
day on the road between Stratford and
Wells Warren slide 2 please this is what
it potentially could look like last
month before this committee we were
opposed to the opinions expressed by
professional consultants but this
committee accepted their opinion partly
because of their professional status
we're asking you therefore to accept the
recommendation of the professional paid
for a consult II and insist the new
building is close to the roadside
hedging
in granting some form of barn
replacement we would further request the
removal of permitted development rights
which could otherwise allow the building
to receive prior approval for change of
use and conversion of agricultural to
residential this would come under
class-m be brackets a of schedule two of
the Turner Country Planning bracket
general permitted development bracket
order 1995 as amended the officers
proposed condition is not strong enough
to prevent the use of permitted
development rules overriding the
neighbourhood plan and creating a
residential dwelling outside the village
settlement boundary we were there from
our Xu to strengthen the condition
relating to the use and withdraw with
the officer yeah thank you any further
questions thank you
right over the Aegean place it natashia
black lord to silver forgot that right
Natasha how good thank you you've got
three minutes and I'll be bored in yes
okay good evening I am here on behalf of
my client to speak in support of the
replacement agricultural building
I thank officers for their constructive
feedback and assistance to date and
fully endorse their positive
recommendation the proposed building has
been located on the eastern boundary on
the site of the existing dilapidated
barn within the existing yard area its
design is typical of an agricultural
building and is not out of keeping with
the character of the area an independent
agricultural appraisal confirmed that
the building of this design size and
height is appropriate and reasonably
necessary for the acreage of this
holding the Parish Council objected to
the building on concerns related to its
height and proposed location suggesting
an alternative the principal of the
building has been accepted I would like
to reiterate that the appraisal agreed
that the height is reasonable to allow
loaders to stack bails stating that if
it was lower in height a larger floor
area would be required to compensate the
Parish Council originally objected to a
slightly larger floor area building in
regards to location siting the building
on the concrete base of the existing
barn is the preferred option and the
officer agrees locating it here allows
the existing track and yard to be
utilized
whereas luli location would require a
new yard area in addition the existing
naught point three five hectare track
and yard would not be available for hill
product for hay production for the
foreseeable future
the appraisal incorrectly says that it
does not appear that the existing
balance has a concrete floor that could
be utilized there actually is a concrete
base and this was the main reason for
the appraisal suggesting the relocation
of the barn the visuals on the screen
show the building in both locations so
the proposed which is about 75 metres
away from the highway and the parish
council alternative which is next the
and outside of the Red Line boundary due
to the low-level hedgerow this option
would be more visually intrusive on the
street scene than the proposed and the
officer report states that this option
may also impacts the existing boundary
trees which are there are three with the
low-level hetero as you saw by the photo
earlier in contrast the trees behind the
proposed location break up the horizon
ensuring that it's not visually opposing
it should be noted that prior
notifications restrict agricultural
buildings from being excited within 25
metres of the road due to visual impacts
whilst not compulsory for a full
application it is still a relevant
consideration by this criteria the
building would need to be located in the
middle of the field rather than on a
fortification which would disrupt
efficient farming the application is
policy compliant and accords with the
appraisal the officer has suggested a
landscaping condition be attached to the
decision notice which we have me accept
and we hope that this is a
straightforward decision to approve the
scheme in line with the officers
recommendation and trust that members
will agree I'm happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you general
storage because you mentioned hey didn't
you it won't be a lifestyle building the
reason I say is because it's fully
enclosed and you don't normally have a
fully enclosed it's not just hay storage
its machinery storage as well obviously
some machinery is quite expensive so you
want a fully enclosed barn to make sure
people don't steal it it is quite common
for general-purpose build agricultural
buildings to be falling apart the need
of the height the four point eight
meters so the agricultural appraisal
says that most hay stacks are four
metres high and with machinery used to
stack them it needs to be 4.8 to the
eave so they can pick them up lift them
and remove them and the height was
agreed with the appraisal that wasn't so
hay and straw in goes to the combustion
comment on that please know the
agricultural appraisal agreed that the
design was alright the height was
alright and what it was going to be
useful was okay so we didn't question it
[Music]
I gather there is a small holding that
is this this is part of the Spanish for
a small holding yes the blue line on the
location plan that we showed earlier is
the land is the income coming as well
from contracting if he's gonna store
materials and machinery in there or is
it the use on the small helping the
machinery stored will be the machinery
that will be used on the holding during
hay production and where else is needed
it is listed in the agricultural
appraisal what items will be needed for
this holding of the calculations will be
done ok sorry I'm I don't know I think
on that one I've got one question if
there anybody else's nobody else has got
one there was comment from the parish
council they would like the permitted
development residential condition
strengthened just what your comments
were well currently I believe that build
agricultural buildings have to predate
March 2013 to be allowed to do permitted
development rights to turn to
residential so for the foreseeable
future wouldn't be allowed anyway unless
that was updated
if they want to have committed
developments put into the condition to
strengthen that I'd accept mr. Barnes
please go sir failed in wait excuse me
thank you
sorry about that I think I answered out
at the moment it wouldn't be eligible
for PD rights under the GP do anyway
thank you
any more questions she sounds or I told
members the public offers the landscape
in will be agreed after yes it's a
condition that's been will be put on the
decision they don't okay thank you very
much
move on two points of clarification any
points okay so Brian then gets the bonds
before it's a fully enclosed building
and we're told it's pretty going to be
predominately used for storage of hay
there's only common the officers
couldn't provide in relation to that
please and yes that point was actually
addressed in the Colonel's report which
and if I could just read this section on
the design of the proposed building this
is directly quoting from Conan's the
building will be fully clad with bobbed
profile cladding with access via rollers
shutter doors although such a design is
appropriate for machinery storage it is
not ideal for hay storage which would be
better accommodated with an open front
of building level however it is
recognized that hay stored in an open
building can be at risk of arson and
therefore given the relatively small
amount of hay that will be stored in the
enclosed building the design proposed is
not inappropriate
can we just clarify a little bit further
with that because they actually specify
the floor area absolutely it's fortunate
meter squared of hay storage and 40
meter squared of machinery and equipment
storage so it's kind of mixed an excuse
right um just wanted to clarify that
first can we have our board member
counts the Mills no please sorry about
that I should have made that clear i
Sean take five minutes seven and
colleagues
yeah I'm bring this up I'm sorry I was
unable to attend the previous committee
meeting now even more sorry where it's
not possible to what or listen to the
reputation by representation my works
your Highway Authority due to technical
problems with this recording however I'm
here now like you have listened to the
parish councils well recent case for
changes to this application I note
they're not opposing the principles
within the MPPs
nor policies within the core strategy
they are supporting rural businesses the
argument appears to me to be based on
solid planning reasons they objected to
the location of the replacement barn
because of the visual impact the
neighborhood de belem plan policy d6
that's reuse of buildings supports the
reuse of buildings providing the
development does not have an
unacceptable impact on the visual and
landscape amenity policy d1 design and
character states that all development in
rural areas should be well designed and
inclusive in keeping in scale with its
location and sensitive to the character
of the countryside and local
distinctiveness the proposal could be
seen to be in breach of both these
policies
what also note is that they are asking
for the guidance offered by the
consultants commissioned by the council
to be adopted the planning officer
suggests that the building could be
adequately screened by some additional
landscaping as yet unspecified how long
will it take for the new landscaping to
grow sufficiently to screen sick a six
meter high building when the consultants
observed that an existing hedgerow can
do the same job with immediate effect
the Parish Council has also requested
that something stronger is conditioned
than the officer suggests and of
agricultural storage storage purpose
only they argue that something stronger
will prevent an easy circumvention of
the neighborhood plans settlement
boundary at any point in the future this
seems eminently reasonable and should be
accepted acceptable to the applicant who
is only wishing to build a storage
facility so I ask you to work with the
Parish Council deferred defer a decision
on this application pending revised
plans indicating of allocation with
relocation from the site of the existing
tissues building to close the roadside
and hedgerow and detailed wording
associated with the withdrawal of the
right to seek prior approval for change
of use through the general limited
development order and this is a favor
lastly since only return from a Holiday
Inn earlier today and there's a tree
about three o'clock this morning if you
do have any questions for me can I
please be permitted to ask a friend like
phone-a-friend if the answer does not
come immediately to mind Thank You mr.
chairman
jet lag Thank You council avails that
was very interesting thank you come to
the question but a lot of agricultural
buildings are being completely filled in
now because
ruh-roh crime what if what is your
concern you think putting me by the gate
would be a good idea
it will be easily observed wouldn't it
from the from the gauge and welding
people will be okay
for you to go counts the nails my let
off yes well they're about two points of
clarification we've had that one point
clarified which I thought was quite
pertinent counselor carriage it just uh
it was mentioned made that about having
to be twenty five meters away from the
road something if you had a new barn it
wasn't supposed to be next to the road
didn't anything about that I think
you've got a larger agricultural holding
you can have committee development
rights to build a new building as long
as it's twenty five meters away from the
road so that's absolutely nothing to do
with this application because it's okay
sorry chairman through you and I suppose
one key element is you're here to decide
what's before you this is what they're
asking for and it's not within your
remit to be able to change that it's
more the fact that you either accept it
and approve it will you refuse it for
good reasoning in relation to that point
perhaps it just helps to say that as
officers alluding to if you've got
larger than five hectares you've got the
right for permitted development rights
to construct an agricultural barn on
notice to the authority but you have to
meet certain criteria and that's what
that related to so it was on the fact
that although it's not within your remit
to say reposition it if you were to
refuse it that's not something they
could come in they'd have to come back
in for another four planning application
that's this just kept so thank you for
reminding me that we are looking at the
application before we should completely
right there was another thing mentioned
about withdrawal obviously the parish
council are worried that in ten years
time this is going to come back as a
house under one of the cou key or
whatever it is
so are we permitted to to say you can't
do that chairman through you in relation
to conditions obviously your starting
point is whether or not they meet the
six Tests
to put that condition on a development
and if it just briefly remind you that
it is they have to be necessary relevant
to planning and to the development to be
permitted enforceable precise and
reasonable in all other respects as you
would appreciate that the permitted
development rights have changed recently
and apart cue in barn conversions but
there has been a restriction put on
through legislation on the basis of new
builds it is the fact that they have to
be there for some considerable time I
would suggest that because of the
legislation and that time period allowed
through the legislation such aspects are
covered through that whereby you
shouldn't condition elements that are
covered by the legislation there has to
be
I would suggest a very good reason to
remove permitted development rights
which you do sometimes have in
circumstances but I'd have to say in
this instance is for you to decide
whether or not you've heard enough to
warrant a condition that makes it
necessary for something that's
speculative in it over a 10-year period
mr Fielding did I not understand the
agent correctly when she said that on
since 2013 that the development rights
were automatically taken away now
chairman through you and that simulation
to the fact that if you have a bomb
that's being in situation and being used
for agricultural use so when they change
the permitted development rights it only
related to agricultural buildings and
barns that had been in city it was on
the basis - obviously central government
just very briefly was looking at
existing barns to be converted if they
met the criteria but not to enable
people to erect barns and then seek a
conversion but I appreciate that
probably a little bit outside of this
meeting to go into further detail the
bonds well I'm right in thinking that
the bond that is there she's concrete
base this application is the same size
weekend as reduced or been reduced to
the same size of the concrete place that
is there at the
and on the the first set of plans that
we had I think 170 square meters
footprint that was revised down but it's
now hundred hundred fifteen still larger
can you see can can you see on the small
gray rectangle that have a smallest grey
rectangle that's the existing footprint
and then the rectangle that's slightly
bigger is the new footprint yeah yeah I
think yeah okay sponsee okay for that
then can I just clarify about the
landscape and Alison I know that there
were still some concerns about that just
emphasize a little bit more but what you
worked on to this piece of this area is
is not the subject of any particular
landscape designation specialized area
or anything but what I would suggest and
I think the applicant is fairly amenable
is to where there's the access track
along along the edge I'll just find a
photograph I would suggest marking the
access track with a new a new hedgerow
so you can see there's a little bit of
hedge own left which can be infilled
back towards the main road but
immediately around the application site
the Samaria which is currently
nettles which I think towards the back
to the north and the south
you could quite easily accommodate some
tree planting there's the brain Anarkali
sorry chair just confirmed so obviously
what the committee looking to do is to
agree that a condition we'd be put on so
that the appropriate landscaping design
would be an effect be delegated to an
offer to to agree directly with the
applicant we're not suggesting that as
it's currently recommended for approval
that there is any further details
containing at this stage it would be for
the officers to determine at that time
okay so Brian thank you gentlemen
two questions really the dilapidated
building would have been that compared
to the new one and the second question
is what will be the material used to
retract or the new bomb I think obvious
stones
track nothing you know nothing
particularly unusual which would be
appropriate to the rural setting in
terms of the height of the existing
building it's a bit difficult to say
because it is it has completely
collapsed but my guess was probably five
meters four meters five meters to the
ridge
I doubt if it's six by looking at
everyone except between four or five
questions points of clarification Johnny
good so can we move to that debate catch
the right Thank You chairman whereas I'm
concerned about the construction of the
building and its use
that's not a planning consideration in
my view send to the applicant what they
use it for and what risks they take I
don't see any reason for a deferral of
the application
I do see a need for some sign of design
for the track up to an approved
materials for that so we don't tarmac in
an open country so my other concern was
the height of the building then it will
be more visual in the open countryside
than what the existing building will be
but I see no real reasons for refusal so
I will go with the officers
recommendation if my colleagues want to
put any extra conditions on I'm sure
they will tell me that's the bond yes
hey he's storage at the moment with
crime going up substantially it does
need to be secured bond that are open
are very vulnerable particularly in
villages so I'm concerned this isn't an
ideal spot but it is a lot better spot
there then it would be next to the edge
next to the road though with the right
conditions of the rural surface and the
landscaping I'm quite happy to animal
accounts the brain proposed if there are
maybe if not I will propose it or second
it whichever wants the materials are
right
Keenan's have had a look at it but
unfortunately I can't see rural crime
going down where we have had two or
three Land Rovers
still stolen this week and that from
where they were stolen three months ago
so doesn't need a secure building
without any holes in it to make sure
it's safe I'm not saying I'm finding it
difficult to understand why such a small
holding needs a building of this sort of
size when all they're producing is hey I
suspect they're probably storing
fertilizer in there in which case it has
to be locked but I see no problem in
approving it along with my colleagues I
think they did mention machinery as well
suppose what needs to be locked
catch the barns sorry cancer brain is
kept the brain second weather my kid
proposed it or not they don't got up we
happy to go to the vote sorry [ __ ]
chairman can I just clarify counselor
did you want to add the it was that with
the extra provision whereby for
arguments a approve of the materials
casually we did just include landscaping
details including track materials well
it would be the track details that would
be great
in one of my villages where we've given
permission for a track they put white
stone down which makes you look terrible
it ought to be a track with the grass at
the center say it does look agricultural
hardcore I think we're there look at
that - officers - so it's a fair point
we've had a proposal second go - all
those in favor
unanimous chairman committee resolved to
grant application 18 / 0 0 806 ful move
on to the next item which is 18 / 0 0 7
2 4 6 ful chasman cottage at Reddington
shipsterns Donna and Louise Casey is our
presenter upset
maybe when you always take something
right then are we ready
it's from the reefs far away Thank You
chair so the application out for members
is for the proposed partial rebuild of
the brief annex to the rear of Jasmine
cottage the rebuild includes the
demolition of the existing brick chimney
and the installation of a flue so the
application site identified by the black
dot is situated within the village of
trading turn and also the village
Conservation Area the application site
is outlined here in red
Jasmine cottage is a two-story of brick
built cottage surrounded by neighboring
dwellings on all sides the adjoining
neighbor and property charity
schoolhouse is grade 2 listed so that's
this property just here so here we've
just got an aerial photo to demonstrate
the relationship between the properties
within the nearby vicinity and here
we've got the existing floor plan / roof
plan of the annex and also the southeast
elevation so now I'll turn into the
proposed plans as you can see the main
visible changes will be the replacement
of the chimney with the flu we've got
the installation of roof lights within
the southwest elevate within the
Southwest roof slope and also some
changes defenestration here the rebuild
would be on the same footprint as the
existing with the same form same height
and same volume and it would also
the existing materials to be reused so
the first image here no also we've got
the location finally indicate in the
position the photos were taken from
first image is looking towards Jasmine
Cottage from the roadsides to the
northwest the second image here shows
used from the roadside to the east and
over the garden of the neighboring it's
the property charter school house
and the third image here is just looking
towards the southeast elevation and
taken from the garden of the application
property and we've got in regards to a
base of the application an additional
condition has been proposed to control
the finish of the flue to be a matte
black finish and chairman it is
recommended to grant the application for
the reason sets out in the report which
can be found on page 29 of the agenda
Thank You Louise
did go black there for a minute what was
going on look of that first speaker
please thank you
now that's fine
pissed in the middle one
it comes on bread I only try the other
one see if that one hopefully will work
right thank you
I think also you should have an overview
photo with the actual house shown so you
know how it how it sits in the village
not the old charges school house which
is listed is the palest own one with the
little car in front and art is the
longer one with the back part where we
need desperately to rebuild the wall
that's adjoining there because it's
terribly damp as the roof is leaking
this should have all been done as you
can imagine earlier in the year that my
husband was taken seriously ill so
everything has just fallen backwards I
did speak not to my immediate neighbors
but the ones way at the top where you
say they have a conservatory and he came
to see me yesterday and he said his main
concern his only concern was you're not
going to put a stainless steel flue are
you because when the Sun shines it'll I
said no it's going to be black so he's
gone away quite happy he lives in France
most of the time so he said no I've gone
and he's happy so I have no problems
with him now I haven't spoken to my
immediate neighbors but I think that
their concern was the stain is still
fluid which is now going to be back
so if anyone wants to ask me anything
Here I am just put your thing on
microphone please being a bit against
any further questions you free to go
you've got cut away lightly you're free
you're free to go you've got away
lightly thank you right in case of white
crayon German the only reason this
application is before us discuss the
applicants husband is a ward member it
would have been dealt with under
delegated it is the only reason it's
here is because he's a ward member and I
would recommend that we go through the
votes for the proposal to grant the
application a second definite caseload
honor all those in finer in the update
yes all those in favor
catch the bonds
unanimous chairman slight interruption
committee mr. grant application 18 / 0 0
766 ful thank you
item number 7 which is application 18 /
0 0 9 5 8 ful me okay are we
yes 14 had the close say from Seelye he
sees def statement so will he has left a
statement so I'll be reading the
statement and we will know but it's
Chairman's decision on this one not
decided I know I've been nominated to
speak for him as well yes there's too
many options go come on Zoey just tell
them to be caught in you carry on thank
you to that application now for four
members is for a single story rear and
side extension at 14 Heather close the
application site is identified by the
black dot and it's situated inside them
the site is outlined in red on this plan
its access from Heather close there's a
public right-of-way that runs it on with
the north of the site the site the
darling itself it's l-shaped and it's
set back within the plot from the
highway it's located in a residential
street with dwellings to the east to the
west and to the south to the north of
the site a st. James prime school
here we've got the existing a proposed
block plan the dwelling is west facing
the green the green arrow points to the
principal elevation where the interest
of the property is located the side of
elevation of the dwelling fronts the
highway the proposed block plan is to
the right of the slide the blue arrow
indicates the position of the proposed
extensions here we have the existing
floor plans and elevations the existing
floor plan roof plan our top there's
lower the existing elevations the
publicly visible elevations will be
numbers 1 & 4 and Livan is the principal
elevation and number 4 is a side
elevation which is visible from hazard
closed now turning to the proposed floor
plans and elevations
the proposed plan floor plans and roof
plan at the top the slide and show the
extensions to the property they pointed
out by the blue arrows the extension to
the rare is this to the side of this
floor plan it provides a larger kitchen
area and a toilet the extension to the
side provides a larger bedroom and
shower room toilet
the elevation plans below show the
extensions the extent of the existing
walls are marked by the dashed lines
moving to the images now this image is
as a principal elevation and the side
elevation is taken from Heather close
there's no brandy treatment which
demarcates the front garden area of the
property second image
it's panning to the to the look to the
left of the last image shows you joining
polish to the west which is number 13
Heather close and you can see the
relationship between the two properties
there is a side and front relationship
this image is safe from the garden of
the application project
is looking towards the side elevation of
number 13 which you saw on the previous
image as you can see there's a window
within the side elevation this image is
the view from that side window of number
13 the preferred side extension would
project from the side of the wall that
can be seen on the left of this image
this image shows in every property to
the east
number 15 had a close it's set behind
the application property and there are a
number of windows within front elevation
and number 15 most of which have non
half double rooms this image is taken
from the rear of the application
property number 15 Heather closes on the
left the three windows which can be seen
here behind the boundary fence served on
half double rooms and obscurely glazed
the extension proposed wooden fill the
gap between the side the array of the
application property and this neighbor
here it's the end of the presentation
there are two updates for members the
first of which is clarification on the
ward member comments no additional
points have been raised the second
approach approach council comments when
they withdrew their objection which were
that novel application should be
submitted for the site
before we move on to the ward member
which is gonna be me and Jen we like to
put point of clarification on the update
sheet for the comments made by the town
council and made by the parish council I
think it's just worth noting that
there's made a common good in relation
to then caveat in their removal of their
objection obviously that's not something
that's legally enforceable by any means
so in effect there objection would still
stand is how it should be deemed because
we cannot agree to include any
conditional provision that would seek to
prevent any of any future application
being put in it would be put in a matter
P for you to determine unless of course
well in fact I guess it would be rather
than any permitted development rights
being removed they would require the
application in any event that makes
sense sometimes you remove we touched on
earlier remove frequented development
rights but in this instance they're not
even saying that they're saying that
they would not want any future
applications being submitted in relation
to the southern with elevation which
obviously is not lawful we cannot agree
to that thank you
so I'll just read statement please
accept the statement as my observations
for the plan our obligation 1809 5 8 F
you are my first observation having as
Wadman but looked at the plans is the
lack of information on the size of the
extension there are no measurements
it appears that while there is a drawing
there's definitely no measurements to
give sizes of the proposed extension not
alone I wouldn't consider a serious note
I note from the Planning Officers report
that finally dimensions are being given
but they should have been shown on the
drawing for members of the public and
particular neighbors so they can get a
fair judgment apologies for lack of
commas
my next observation is the extension
appears to be out of character with thee
within an area which has never had an
extension work carried out in over forty
years of the roads existence I would
point out that some of the percentages
of one usage based on balance officers
report are not ones given which are
going on point eight of brink of no
dimensions have been rejected in an
application in nearby then you're owed I
feel like we must be consistent in our
policy as a council it's currently a
covenant in place which prevents any
extensions while the planning office is
correct in that this is not a Pawnee
mater in the interest of openness and to
prevent possible legal action the
District Council should as a condition
make it clear that in such applications
that the applicant should follow the
correct procedure of appeal in the
current covenant and also make local
residents clear the the correct
procedure before any work can be started
this article should be undertaken by a
letter to each of the residents and have
the class and research legal presidents
in regard to this particular issue it
will prevent possible action against
both the upper current on the council
and be in line with guidelines from the
upper tribunal following the case in
2013 I would recommend that should the
committee be monta to grant the
application in this condition be placed
on the application the contact details
for the tribunal can be made available
if required overall this is the street
that since being built has not had any
properties modified by way of extensions
or loft conversions and is very unique
in that virtually of it other Street and
say of them has homes that have been
modified and I feel that it is important
that the character of the street and its
original design purpose is kept which
has been the case for over 40 years
okay so Tony promise
thank you I need comments points
complication catch the brain or member
value I think okay I say there's no
opportunity for us to question anybody
even got no objectors I suggest we go to
the office recommendation neighbor
neighbor neighborhood problems and
boundary disputes how is that extension
to the boundary the extensions right up
to the boundary but number the number 15
has a side access semi took up between
the dwelling itself but the extension
will be built up right to the boundary I
know is I know as men she's not a
planning issue but his covenants would
they have an in there be enforced
chairman through you as you depreciate
there are matters that fall outside the
planning regime you often having a
situation where whether whether there
might be private rights of way and
they're not matters for the planning
committee in the same way
private covenants that are entered into
that are no doubt record on the Land
Registry which is how that people have
become aware of them are not planning
considerations for you it's a civil
matter and it's just not simply
something that should be given any
weight change the bonds sorry I'm happy
again second cancer brain foot forward
both the Town Council I'm the warden in
but I'm able to come
Jenna - can we just clarify that that
was the proponents on those it's going
with the officers statement but he did
that's fine thank you
yeah no just to make sure better safe
than sorry so we go to the right on this
one place all those in favor of granting
one for chairman against one chairman
one chairman committee committee
resolves to grant application 18 / 0 0 9
v AK fu well okay so I think you just
sit down a minute please thank you
having any urgent business
no chairman thank you very much and I
mean I declare the meeting closed thank
you